we in the uk still hope that diplomacy
and dialogue may yet succeed
but we also have to be unflinchingly
honest about the situation today
when over 130 000 russian troops are
gathering on the borders of ukraine and
when more than 100 battalion tactical
groups threaten that european country
we must be united against that threat
because we should be in no doubt what
is at stake here
if
ukraine is invaded and if ukraine
is overwhelmed we will witness the
destruction
of a democratic state
a country that has been free for a
generation
with a proud history
of elections
and every time that western ministers
have visited kiev
we've assured the people of ukraine and
their leaders
that we stand foursquare behind
their sovereignty
and independence
how hollow
how meaningless
how insulting
those words would seem if
at the very moment when their
sovereignty and independence is
imperiled
we simply look away
if ukraine is invaded the shock
will echo
around the world
and those echoes will be heard in east
asia they will be heard in taiwan
when i spoke to the prime ministers of
japan
and australia this week
they left me in no doubt that the
economic and political shocks would be
felt on the far side of the world so
let me be clear
about the risk
the risk now
is that people would draw the conclusion
that aggression pays
and that might
is right
so we should not underestimate the
gravity of this moment
and what is at stake
as i speak to you today we do not fully
know what president putin
intense
but the omens are grim and that is why
we must stand strong
together
the uk has worked with the european
union and the united states to put
together the toughest and strongest
package of sanctions and i spoke
recently to president ursula van der
lion to discuss the measures prepared by
the eu in closest coordination with our
own
and if russia invades
its neighbor
we will
sanction
russian individuals and companies of
strategic importance to the russian
state and we will make it impossible for
them to raise finance on the london
capital markets and we will open up
the matryoshka dolls of russian-owned
companies and russian-owned entities to
find the ultimate beneficiaries
within
and if president putin believes that by
these actions he can
drive nato back or intimidate nato
he will find that the opposite is the
case already the uk and our allies are
strengthening the defenses of the
eastern flank of nato we're increasing
the british contribution to exercise
cold response by sending our newest
aircraft carrier hms prince of wales and
three commando brigade we're doubling
our presence in estonia to nearly 2 000
troops
we've increased our presence in poland
to 600 troops by sending 350 marines
from 4-5 commando
we've increased our presence in the
skies over southeastern europe with
another six typhoons based in cyprus
we're sending warships to the eastern
mediterranean and the black sea and i've
placed another 1 000 troops on standby
to respond to any humanitarian emergency
which we all fear is increasingly likely
and while the most alarming and the most
visible threat is the massing of russian
land forces on ukraine's borders look at
the naval buildup in the black sea which
threatens to blockade ukraine look at
the massive cyber attacks and the
incoming tide
of disinformation
this crisis extends into every domain
which is why the uk is providing nato
with more land sea
and air forces
and it is because we feared a crisis
like this
that we were already engaged in the
biggest increase in defence investment
for a generation spread across
conventional capabilities and the new
technologies that are ever more
important to our collective defense and
i'm proud to say
that since russia invaded ukraine for
the first time and annexed crimea in
2014 we have been helping ukraine
training 22 000 troops and in recent
months in response to the threat we have
been among the nations to send defensive
weaponry in the form of 2000 anti-tank
missiles and i'm glad that we've been
joined in this by the united states
by poland
and by our baltic allies
and that many other nations and the eu
have like the uk helped to strengthen
ukraine's economy
britain
will always stand up for freedom and
democracy around the world
and when i say that our commitment to
european security is immovable and
unconditional our deeds show that we
mean
our words
we are making the biggest contribution
of nato
to nato of any european ally because we
understand the importance of collective
security and just as our european
friends
stood by us after the russian state used
chemical weapons
in salisbury used a chemical weapon in
salisbury
so britain will stand by you
but we must accept that these measures
by the uk and our allies draconian
sanctions rinsing out dirty money the
intensification of nato's defenses
fortifying our ukrainian friends they
may not be enough
to deter russian aggression and it is
therefore vital that we learn the
lessons of 2014.
whatever happens in the next few days
and weeks we cannot allow european
countries to be blackmailed by russia we
cannot allow the threat of russian
aggression to change the security
architecture of europe we cannot permit
a new yalta a new division of our
continent into spheres of influence and
we must now wean ourselves of dependence
on putin's oil and gas and i understand
the the costs and the complexities
of this effort and the fact that it is
easier said than done so i'm grateful to
chancellor schultz's assurances about
nordstrom 2
but the lessons of the last few years
and of gazprom's obvious manipulation of
european gas supply cannot be ignored
we must ensure that by making full use
of alternative supplies and technology
we make russia's threats redundant and
that will be the work of the months and
years to come as well as the necessary
overdue steps that we in the uk must
take to protect our own financial system
and we now need to prepare ourselves
for the russian playbook of deception
that governs every operation of this
kind
there will be a cascade of false claims
about ukraine intended to spread
confusion almost for its own sake
and even now there are plans being laid
for staged events spinning a web of
falsehoods designed to present any
russian attack as a response to
provocation
we've already witnessed a fake military
withdrawal combined with staged
incidents that could provide a pretext
for military action
we knew this was coming
we've seen it before
and no one should be fooled
and we have to steal ourselves for the
possibility of a protracted crisis
with russia maintaining the pressure and
searching for weaknesses over an
extended period
and we must together refuse
to be worn down
what europe needs is strategic endurance
and we should focus our energies on
preserving our unity and on deepening
transatlantic cooperation
but for that to work we must also be
prepared to devote the necessary
resources to carry a greater share of
the burden of preserving our continent's
security and to demonstrate
that we are in it for the long haul
for now
we should continue
to do everything we can
to pursue the path of peace and dialogue
there is a way forward
if president putin
is minded to take it there is a
discussion to be had
about the threats that he claims to see
because in reality as we all know those
threats are an illusion
they are the product of the kremlin's
chronic but misguided view of nato as a
supposedly encircling and intimidating
alliance
that is not nato's function nato is a
peaceful and a defensive alliance
and we are willing to work with
president putin to demonstrate that
point and to give him the assurances
that he may need we could point out
that until he invaded ukraine for the
first time in 2014
nato did not permanently station any
troops anywhere
east of germany
and it was as recently as 2017 that the
us the uk
and other nato allies established the
enhanced forward presence to protect
poland and the baltic states and even
then
the total deployment
of fewer than 5 000 troops
posed no conceivable threat to russia
and it is only in the last few weeks in
response to the current crisis that we
have dispatched reinforcements though
still in numbers that constitute no
possible threat until 2014
european allies were cutting
their defense budgets and shrinking
their armed forces perhaps faster
than was safe
or wise
and to the extent that this has changed
it is because of the actions of
president putin and the tension that he
has created
if nato forces are now closer to
russia's border it is in response to his
decisions and the justified concerns
they have provoked among our allies and
there are many things said about what
may or may not have been said in the
closed door meetings of three decades
ago as the berlin wall fell and germany
was reunited but there is no doubt
that we all agreed
legal obligations to protect the
security of every country in europe
and
uh what happened
in in those amazing years
was the dissolution of the iron curtain
and the fulfillment
of the vision of a europe whole and free
it was one of the most incredible
moments of my lifetime as nations at the
heart of our continent regained their
liberty and their sovereign right to
control their own destiny
and seek their own alliances
we will not abandon the hope and impulse
of that era
made possible by the courage of millions
of ordinary europeans and that's why
nato opened its doors to 14 states after
1999
and we cannot allow our open door
to be slammed shut
but if dialogue fails
and if russia chooses to use violence
against an innocent and peaceful
population in ukraine
and to disregard the norms of civilized
behavior between states and to disregard
the charter of the united nations
then we at this conference should be in
no doubt
that it is in our collective interest
that russia
should ultimately fail
and be seen
to fail
i believe that in preparing to invade
ukraine a proud country whose armed
forces now exceed 200 000 personnel
considerably more expert in combat today
than in 2014
president putin and his circle are
gravely
miscalculating
i fear that a lightning war would be
followed by a long and hideous period of
reprisals and revenge and insurgency
and russian parents would mourn the loss
of young russian
soldiers
who in their way are every bit as
innocent as the ukrainians now bracing
themselves for attack
and if ukraine is over overrun by brute
force i fail to see how a country
encompassing nearly a quarter of a
million square miles the biggest nation
in europe apart from russia itself could
then be held down and subjugated forever
after a
generation of freedom
we're now staring at a generation of
bloodshed
and misery
i believe that russia would have
absolutely nothing to gain from this
catastrophic venture and everything
to lose
and
while there is still time i urge the
kremlin to de-escalate to disengage its
forces from the frontier and to renew
our dialogue every nation at this
conference shares a vision of secure and
of a secure and prosperous europe of
sovereign states deciding their own
destiny and living without fear or
threat and that extends that vision of
course
extends to russia
a nation whose cultural patrimony we
revere
and whose sacrifice in the struggle
against fascism was immeasurable
russia has as much right as any other
country
to live in peace and security
and we should never cease to emphasize
that russia has nothing to fear
from our vision which threatens and
marginalizes no one
and as we come together in unity and
resolve we must also show wisdom
and moderation
because it's precisely
by that unity
that we show today that we have the best
chance
even now
at this
11th hour
of averting disaster
and ensuring
that good sense
can still prevail